FACE OFF
BUBBLE IN THE WESTERN
CONFERENCE AND ARSTICKHANDLING.
PIETRANGELO, SAVED JODI
HARD YOU REN'T NORMALLY.
IT IS REALLY DIFFICULTIT.
BROSSOIT.
FOLLOWING THE PUCK FROM HIS
LEFT TO RIGHT.
AS HUDSON GETS HIS STICK ON  TH
IN THE EARLY GOINGS.D BY ANDERS
A HALFSTEP FASTER.
ALL OF THEM.
SHOT,
JEFF SKINNER, HAVING A NICE
REVIVAL THIS YEAR,
EICHEL WINS THE FACE-OFF.
SEE IF VEGAS S
WRAPAROUND, PACIORETTY KNOW,
TRIES AGAIN,  ATTACK TO
THE NET QUICKLY, CRAIG ANDERSON
IS ABLE TO GET A ST
WHAT I SAY BY
SAVED BY BROSSOIT AS HE TRIED S
SAMUELSSON.
BEHIND TUCH, A CHANCE TO  UNAVA
DON'T FORGET, HE TOOK TWO SHOTS
AS HE WAS NEED POINTS.L.
HE HAS HAD A LOT OF TAKEAWAYS
IN HIS OWN ZONE.
I'M NOT SURE IF I WAS ON SITE
OR NOT, TUCH TRIES TO GO
BUFFALO RETURNS.
IN FRONT IS LOOSE.
COCO
REDIRECTION,  OFOF
HE DUCKED DOWN LIKE M IN THE FA
CARRIER DUCKS, PERFECTLTL
>> John: POWERPLAY GOAL!
BROSSOIT LOOKS  UP AS HE  SPOT!
KREBS SCORED.ONE OF
THEM.
EICHEL CAN'T KEEP THE PUCK INTO
GET